TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now, Glass
is a new platform.
In fact, it's a new form
of technology.
And because of that, we need
new rules for the road, new
guidelines, if you will, to
know how to build these
services for users.
We've come up with four
guidelines that make sense for
the services that we've built.
And we think they're
going to be really
useful for you as well.
The first of which is
to design for Glass.
Now, Glass is a unique platform
that is both mobile
but fundamentally different than
existing mobile platforms
in both design and use.
You want to build your Glass
service with this in mind.
Design it specifically
for Glass.
Ensure that the user experience
is appropriate for
Glass by testing
on the device.
You need to wear this service
throughout your day, during
the week, in the evenings,
to really know how it
fits into your life.
Now, a great example of this is
that you wouldn't want to
read an entire news
story on Glass.
When you put on Glass, you
know it's great for those
short interactions, when you
need access to information
right then.
Reading headlines and reading
photos is really, really
great, but you wouldn't want to
sit there and read a whole
article like you would
be reading a book.
The second guideline I want
to talk about is,
don't get in the way.
Now this seems simple,
but it's really key.
Because users want Glass there
when they need it, when they
want it, but out of the
way when they don't.
You want to make sure that your
service provides for this
desire by not being too
frequent and loud with
notifications, and provide
appropriate controls for the
optimum user experience, and
never take precedence.
The user's life comes first.
Now, a great example here is
that you wouldn't want to
insert a modal dialogue as a
timeline card for the user.
And what I mean by that is you
wouldn't want to give them a
timeline card, whereas if they
don't respond to it, your
service stops working
for them.
Rather, the timeline cards you
insert should be something
that, if they look at, it's
great, but if they miss it,
it's no big deal.
A third guideline is
keep it timely.
Glass is a very now device.
You can think of your phone
as information that you're
looking at for today or perhaps
this week, your laptop
for maybe this month, your hard
drives at home for the
last year or so.
But Glass is something that
you're carrying throughout
your day that you look at when
you need something right now.
And the data that you provide
should be that.
It's most effective when it's in
the moment and up to date.
Now, an example is that you
wouldn't want to insert a
timeline card that's an
email from a week ago.
You'd rather give the user an
email that just came in and is
important to them.
The last one here is avoid the
unexpected, and particularly
the unexpected and
the unpleasant.
You want to be transparent with
the user and give them
the functionality that
you promised.
Now, you're going to want to
do this on any platform but
especially on Glass, because
the user is wearing it.
An example here is that if I
were to share photos with your
service, and then you also
insert timeline cards that
describe new features on your
web property, that's going to
be inappropriate.
I mean that's a newsletter that
I'm going to want to read
in my inbox.
I didn't sign up for that.
And by giving that to me, it's
going to hurt my overall user
experience with your service.
So let's go through those
one more time.
The four guidelines are, first,
design for Glass.
Glass is new.
And you need to design
specifically for it as a user
experience.
You don't want to
get in the way.
You want to provide information
there for the
user, when they want it, but you
want to be completely out
of the way when they don't.
You want to keep it timely.
Glass is about right now.
Provide up to date information
and respond to
the user right away.
And finally, you want to avoid
the unexpected, and especially
the unexpected and unpleasant.
Give the user the service
that they signed up for.